al menos 64 millones de turcos
estuvieron llamados a las urnas desde
las ocho de la mañana de este domingo
unos 192 mil puntos de votación estaban
dispuestos pero dos se llevaron toda la
atención en las que ejercieron su
derecho al voto los dos principales
candidatos a la presidencia el
mandatario reyecta y su contrincante que
malquistarol glue la jornada inició para
erdoan con unos minutos dedicados a la
oración en la mezquita Santa Sofía
tiempo después se dirigió al centro
electoral
Espero que una vez que se hayan contado
los votos para nuestro país para nuestra
nación para nuestra democracia Un buen
futuro de mi Dios para mi país para mi
pueblo y para la democracia turca
por su parte quilisstaroglu depositó su
boleta en una sala abarrotada por medios
de comunicación
extrañamos la democracia extrañamos
estar juntos besarnos ya verán si Dios
quiere la primavera volverá a esta
tierra y los manantiales fluirán
A las afueras del sitio una multitud lo
esperaba para saludarlo la opinión de
los votantes contaba con un factor común
El Deber de elegir por el bien del país
lo importante en esta lección es no
dividir a Turquía espero siga así todos
están tratando de ganarse la vida no hay
nada más que hacer cumpliré más con
nuestro deber
diversos factores estuvieron sobre la
mesa a la hora de emitir el voto entre
ellos el tema económico con una
inflación galopante que afecta al país y
el aspecto político al decidir la
continuidad de la dirección de la nación
o el cambio con un candidato en favor de
suavizar las relaciones con occidente